welcome to another famous Friday where
we look at famous entrepreneurs and help
you model their success to make your
business grow today's lesson is show me
if you have a new idea a new concept
something that's revolutionary so this
is going to change the world then you
need to show me how it works don't just
come to me with a piece of paper or a
PowerPoint file or an email and say
here's the blueprints here's how it's
going to work show me it working because
the bigger the idea is the more unique
it is the newer it is the more people
are going to be skeptical that it's
going to work so instead of just trying
to solve them with an email or
PowerPoint presentation sell them by
actually showing them how your product
or service works so one of my favorite
examples is from Henry Ford and Ford
founder of the Ford Motor Company
legendary entrepreneur when he first
started he was an engineer he was an
engineer at Edison electrical and was
helping create electricity for America
and he wanted to do his own thing you
know he wanted to be an entrepreneur he
had ideas - you didn't one just worked
for somebody else and so he wanted to
get into the car business and and the
car business was super new nobody was
really making cars a whole bunch of
Engineers just creating their own
inventions and so he came up with his
own invention and he called the
quadricycle and the quadricycle were
basically two bicycles that were
attached together with a gasoline engine
in the middle and that was one of the
very first cars in America was his
primitive design and he wanted to get
funding for this and he wanted to quit
his job and he wanted to go and create a
company building quadricycles and it was
such a new crazy idea you know people
were used to riding horses
why would I ride this contraption
quadricycle thing and so instead of just
going out and pitching people on with
the prospectus on paper
Wood Eaton was he built his first
quadricycle and he wanted to go to
William Murphy who was a highly
successful entrepreneur in the lumber
business
and when he went to pitch him he showed
up in his quadricycle a working
quadricycle prototype unit and he took
William Murphy for a ride on it
around town and by the end of the ride
they were in business together that's
how it works it's so much easier to
convince people to give you money to buy
from you to refer people to you to put
you in the media to have you be guests
on their shows whatever it is you're
looking for it's so much easier for
people to understand what you do when
they can experience it when you're not
just talking about it but they can feel
it and so if you want to sell your idea
if you want to get investors you want to
get customers you want to get momentum
then show me make me feel it believe
those are watching you like this video
you can support me by clicking on the
link in the description leave a comment
let me know what you think and click on
my face to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon